well next up inc reports that delta
airlines is blocking out entire rows
that can only be reserved by groups of
three or making it more
easy for families to sit together so if
you're traveling alone and one of those
seats is like sorry you can't have it
now if you're in a group or with a
family you can actually book it out
because all of us who have families know
how hard that is to do oh yeah but i
will say a lot of my friends who don't
have families don't like this concept at
all well listen there is nothing more
annoying than when you you're traveling
with somebody and you can't get seats
next to each other and you have to do
that dance of like oh excuse me do you
do you mind a window seat or do you and
then right and then have you ever done
that and someone said no i mean and then
you just stare at them the whole
risk you know what you did i hope you're
comfortable
it's true it's like if it doesn't go the
right way it goes the wrong way yeah and
there's have you heard of karma that's
gonna come back to you you know but some
people like have real preferences
they're like i want to be on the aisle
because i have to pee every five minutes
or i like a window i paid for a window i
get it i will say how many people travel
here with kids
oh that sounds awful
that sounds so terrible i and i love
that i love motherhood i would i now
know motherhood so i'm in
my first choice but i love motherhood
well i'm telling you when you travel
with kids and a little group it is so
hard to find seats together you end up
bothering that person almost every
flight and it's awful so i like this
from delta i think it's cool and i think
others should follow suit it's just a
few rows
oh wait can i ask you what other hood is
you just threw that out like i'm
supposed to know i'm now i'm looking up
the dictionary other hood other hood
what is it i call other hood what you do
if you don't have kids
that drew barrymore you're a genius
other hood did you make that up
yeah we'll copyright it dear copyright
it own it
little circle r
but we gotta send a quick thanks out to
the man and the brand that's been
hydrating us all here for the last two
seasons we launched our show in a
pandemic and jason mamoa kindly helped
sponsor our show with mananalu water i
actually do posts about this water all
the time because i'm so obsessed with it
if you put these in the fridge the metal
it makes it like spa water exactly and
it's so good for the planet thank you
this is what we've been looking for i
love you jason
[Music]
you